Ali, how you doing, bro? Good. How about
you, man? The live yesterday from from
Liiano, man, you got cooked. I did.
What? He cooked me on. What he cook? I'm
want your opinion. Everything Everything
this Give me one point. Give me Give me
one point. Wait, wait, wait. I think all
your views. I'm I'm getting Hold on. I
try to get one point. I just want one
point. You don't got to come up here and
be a bot if you He just left. What's up
with these guys? Guys, look to my Muslim
Uma out there who loves the channel and
loves to follow me and loves watching me
and loves my engagements. If you guys
believe that there is a a debate that
you that your guy won and you come up
and you tell me that that I got cooked,
that I got baked, that I lost um in some
capacity, I want to hear from you. I
want to hear what the point was that I
lost on, what the point was on the
opposite side that made sense and that
was coherent and how it refuted me.
Okay? So, if you're going to come up and
say, "Hey, you lost," you're going to be
pressed to explain how. Okay, let's
bring up Kuram. Yo. Yo. So, are you just
purposely misrepresenting what he was
saying or you just doing it just cuz you
don't understand or something? Okay.
Okay. So what did what did he say? He
gave the beard as an example which he
clearly stated, oh an example is my
beard, right? When he was making an
example for what? What I thought was
pretty clear was that the what makes you
different humans is the accidents.
Meaning I I didn't ask about what makes
us different humans. I asked about what
makes us different persons. And he
mentioned his beard. Okay. Yeah. It's
the same thing. He said the beard as an
example and he said, "So, are you
ignoring the part about the accidents?
Do you know what he means by accidents?"
Well, these are these are just things
that are descriptions of his human body.
These aren't permanent things that make
him who he is, right? So, you understand
what he meant by accidents? Yes. Which
is why that didn't answer. So, can you
tell me when he mentions accidents,
right? descriptions like temporary
descriptions of himself. How does that
answer my question of what makes him
what makes Libiano the person a
different person from Avery? How is
Libyano the person not Avery the person?
How does him talk about his accident?
And like he said when he brought up the
accidents for example which is a
different example, right? The beard was
one example. Yeah. You talk about the
beard. Talk about the beard. How does
the beard answer the question? The beard
is just an example. You know, accidents
means there's more than one thing that
makes this person different from him.
Meaning your accidents is what made you
where you're born, where you're from,
who your parents are. No. Okay. So, so
for example, he means by accident. Wait,
hold on. For example, when I when I ask
what makes Libby Liiano and he mentions
his beard and then I said different
accent. Wait, hold on. No, he mentions
his beard. Kuram, just just follow me
for a second. Okay. But you are denying.
You're denying at the same time. So,
Karam, does somebody's beard make them
the person they are? No, obviously not.
Just beard, but
what was my question? What was my
question? Yo, bro. Bro, bro, I know I
know you're hurt and you can't take a L
like What was my question? But I asked
you. Nice coping. Nice try. It doesn't
work here. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. What was my
question? I don't have to cope. Trust
me. Okay.
The question was, what makes Libyano a
different human than a I think I think
that if you're not going to be able to
represent what I asked, I don't think
that you can come up here and and decide
what was said is wrong or right when you
don't even you can't even repeat the
question. So, I'll give I'll give it to
you again cuz I said it to you. I'll
give it to you again. Talk about I'm
going to give it to you again. I'm
giving you the question, bro. Bro, bro,
listen. I know I know how you work. All
right. You could keep Thank you. So the
question was the question was the
question was what makes Libyano a
different person from Avery? That's
literally what I just said. That's
exactly how does him bringing up his
beard answer my question? Okay. So when
you just said okay, you conceded that I
understood it and re restated your
question exactly how it was. So you just
came at me for not de understanding your
question. Take care of yourself. Can
another idiot come up and maybe do a
little bit better? All right, Peter.
Welcome back, Peter. Yo, Logic, what's
up, man? Hey, you remember me from uh
from the last time where you didn't
answer none of my questions? I remember
you from last time. I don't remember not
answering none of your questions,
though. I know. I know. But Logic, I'm
going to keep it like in I'm going to
keep it like fair. You did get cooked,
bro. Like, we got to keep it fair. Look,
listen. You were asking him questions in
the end. He answered your questions, but
the primary the So, do you So, do you
agree with me? Hold up. Hold up. The
main question. Peter, one second. One
second. Okay, I got you. The main
question that I got you, Peter. I got
Peter. Do you want to do you want to
last on the stage? Cuz I don't I don't
mind people sharing their opinions. Do
you want to last on the stage? You want
to talk? Yeah, because he's moving
forward. Let's talk. No. Nope. You
already said something. Now it's my
turn. Do you agree with Liiano that his
beard makes him a distinct person from
me? No. He was using an example simply
that he has a beard that you don't have.
A simple beard. Hold on. Wait. Hold on a
second. You already said no. Hold on.
Cut me off. You said you you already
said no. Well, hold on a second. Let me
talk. I I when I when I when I Okay, so
when I asked him what makes Liiano a
different person from Avery and he
mentioned his beard. Yeah. So he said
his beard makes him a different person
from Avery, right? Yes. Do you point?
Hey, listen. Yeah. Do you agree with
that? Let me provide Let me provide Let
me provide a statement for Do you agree
with trying to say? He keeps cutting me
off, bro. I'm asking, do you agree with
that? Tell you why. I'm asking you,
Peter, it's okay. Just you agree. So,
all right. So, just to be clear, and I'm
going to let you talk. Just to be clear,
you agree that somebody's beard that
they have on their human body makes them
a distinct person from another. Mainly
between you and Libyano. Let me tell you
why. Let me tell you why. Because
Lebaniano, he he was trying to use the
example that he has a beard that you
don't have, which distincts you and him
and makes you guys both different. That
was his main example. And uh to add up
on that and to go with that flow and he
was trying to prove to you that other
world me
you just addressed that beer, he'll
change your argument. I got it. I got
it. Peter. Peter. Does him having a
beard? Before Peter, Peter, if he
doesn't have a beard, is he still let
me? What? If he doesn't have a beard,
I'll say it slower. Just like I did
point. If he doesn't have a beard, I'm
sorry, Peter. I'm sorry. I'm sorry,
Peter. If he doesn't have a beard,
let's go ahead and do this cuz I know
you're panicking just like he did. If he
doesn't have a beard, if he doesn't have
a beard, is he still Libyano? That's his
Yeah, that's his whole argument. So if
he doesn't have a beard, he's still a
biano. That's his whole argument. I need
a yes or no. In every other world where
he doesn't have a beard, he's still a
just like every
that's his whole in every other world.
Take care of yourself, man. Thank you.
So just like just like Liviano, you fell
into the same trap and mistake for how
dumb and stupid you both are. You just
said that the the the beard doesn't
determine the person Libyano is. So
Libbyiano could have the beard and still
be Libbyiano. Libbyo cannot have the
beard and still be Libyano. So the beard
is not what makes Libyano a different
person from me. So what is it? What is
the necessary property that makes
Libyano Libyano and not me Libbyiano?
Are you guys that dumb? I mean I know I
know I'm talking with Muslims. I'm
dealing with Islam. But I do not mind I
do not mind any Muslim that agrees with
Libyano on the point that he's made. You
can come up and defend it all you want.
Come up and try to defend it. I have no
problem. We're going to have thousands
of people watching this watching you
guys make the same stupid point over and
over and over again. And it's going to
show how Islam just produces dumb bots.
That's all. So, keep coming. I'm I'm not
I'm not going to kick nobody. I'm going
to let you guys give your opinion. Say
how Libyano cooked for the Muslim side.
Everybody else was laughing at you guys
in the chat. I'll let you guys up. All
right. So, you guys can deal with this
subject. You guys could tell me where I
can find Muhammad mentioned in the NGO,
mentioned in the gospel, or you could
tell me how how Libyan's beard makes him
a different person than me. No, no
worries. I I'll give you all a chance.
What's up, man? Yeah, what's good, bro?
Liiano baked you, bro. That debate was
insufferable, bro. Oh my days. He would
not answer his question.
So So just to be clear, I ask that you
come up cuz you DM me, dude. Just like
that. It's okay. I don't care. I don't
care. I didn't even watch that debate.
But if you want to try to cook him now,
cook him now. I'm going to mute up. But
please don't don't don't make me look
stupid. Oh yeah. This is on you. This is
on you. Speaking muscle. So So Mazine,
so you agree with Liiano that his beard
makes him a different person than than
me? I mean, not like not like the the
beard just, but he explained. That's
what he said. He explained it's an
example. It's a It's an example of what
an example of what? Makes him a
different person. Yes. Okay. So, if he
didn't have a beard, would he still be
Liiano? But that's not the part I'm
focused on. That's what I asked from the
beginning. That's not That's not what I
asked. If he didn't have a beard, would
he still be Libyano? Yes. So his beard
So his beard is not a deciding factor on
whether he's Liiano or Avery. Correct?
No, but it's an example. So how is the
how is the beard how is bringing up his
beard an example of showing a a
necessary distinction between or
necessary property that makes Libiano
distinct from Avery? How is bringing up
the beard relevant to that question?
Okay, so if he shaves his beard, he's
still Libbyiano. All right, I'm not I'm
not denying that. Okay. But his beard is
one of the distinctions
between you and him. Is is I I I'll say
it again. Is is is his beard
um a property of his person? Yeah, it's
a hypothetic property. Okay. So, is it
something that that makes him different
from Avery the person? Is that a necess
is that a necessary Okay. So if so my so
uh Liiano's beard is a necessary
hypoatic property that makes him
distinct from me. Yeah. Yeah. It's a
it's a property that makes him distinct
from you. If he didn't have the beard
then he wouldn't be Libbyo anymore then.
Right. Even though if he beard he still
be Liiano. Then how is that then how is
that a necessary property that makes him
Liiano the person distinct from Avery
the person? Okay. Again it's not that.
It's um listen, Kam said the exact same
thing. You had the exact same response.
Okay. And then you didn't respond to
him. Okay. Um what what else did he say?
Right. Cuz he didn't only say why are
you running away from this? Why are you
running away from this? I'm not I'm not
running away from anything. He gave the
beard as an example. What was his point?
What was his actual He gave the beard an
example to what question that was asked?
I can't remember what the question was.
But you said I got baked. You said I got
destroyed. And you can't remember the
conversation. The question was The
question was, are there necessary
properties that are applied to
personhood rather than essence? He says,
"No, there's no such thing. There's no
such thing as necessary or essential
hypoatic properties or necessary
qualities that make a person who they
are." He said that doesn't exist. Yes, I
agree. You agree?
There's only two categories. Okay. So
for example um is rational is
rationality is rationality um an
essential property to being a person? Is
rationality an essential property to
being a person essential to the person
or to the essence personhood?
It's no it's not essential to
personhood. So you can be a person
without having any rationale without
having any intellect. No mind it's
essential to essence. I want to ask you
can you be a person without having
intellect without having a mind? No. Cuz
it's essential to essence. You guys are
so confused. So it is it is essential
for rationale to be present for
personhood to exist. Correct. Yeah. So
it's an essential property of personhood
to have um to have intellect to have
rationality. Correct. Yeah. Listen
listen. All right. This is what this is
what I say about the dates. Okay. You're
not going to answer this question. Okay.
I'm I'm not concerned with this, bro.
You are concerned. You are cuz you're
saying that you agree with Libyano that
there are no essential hypoatic
properties. That there are no properties
that are essential to hypoasis. But you
just admitted that my problem is not
with the position. Okay. I I I don't
know Jack about all this philosophy
stuff. My problem is with the debate.
But you said that he you said that he
cooked me on this. If you if you're
saying that you don't know anything
about this stuff that we're talking
about, how can you say that he baked me?
Cuz I watched cuz I watched the debate.
So if you watched the debate, did you
hear him say that his beard is what
makes him a different person than Avery?
I I'll tell you what I did here. I heard
him first two minutes. He asked you a
question. Okay. Um cuz you said um can
can there be a I just want I just want
to know if you agree with this cuz
you're wasting my time. I want to know
if you agree with this. Okay. Just just
let me speak. I I I'll tell you why I
think he cooked you. Do you know that?
Do you do you know his point in the
debate? He he celebrated as if he proved
a proved a point, right? That was part
of the debate, right? Okay. That's nice.
Okay. So, do you agree with him that he
was correct that his beard makes him a
different person than me?
Just give me a second. All right. All
right. Take care, bro. Then answer the
question. Okay. I can't answer the
question. Cool. Like, why can't you
answer the question? Does it come out of
me, man? You speak Arabic? coming out of
shoot
like you if you don't know just I don't
know I don't know there you go
conversation's done so this is what it
is if you're going to come up and say
that I got baked and then I ask you
about a point in the argument that you
saying that I got baked on and you then
say that you don't know after all of
that after all that after all that don't
come up here saying that I got baked
when you don't know even the argument or
you can't even articulate it yourself
you can't back Libyano up on nothing
that he said. Don't come up here with
that type of energy. Does Does it make
sense? Does it make sense to you that a
that a beard is a quality that makes a
person a person? Do you agree with that?
Yes. That's that's the story. So very
good. If if so, watch this. So if a
beard is a quality that makes a person a
person, then not having that beard would
mean that that person is no longer that
person anymore. Right? If he didn't have
that beard, he wouldn't be Libyano.
Correct? No. He's saying he gave beards
as an example. He's saying all of his
qualities together. If he didn't tell
them, he's not he's not Libyan. Take
care of yourself. Take care of yourself.
No, Mazin sounds young. He is young. Um,
people shouldn't be influenced by social
media influencers
so much that No, I'm serious. Like,
think about this. Like, like, you know,
go read the Quran, speak to the but like
don't don't just defend people for their
cuz you love them for the sake of God or
anything like that. Like, like I've
learned this. This is why I'm sitting
here just letting people kind of speak
on their own because everybody has to go
through the process of learning and
frankly some things like you don't
necessarily need to acknowledge
everything but yeah I just told him like
you know if you don't know the answer
bro just say you don't know move on like
this is torture just watching frankly